bonjour bernard bûcher bonjour à tous
vous êtes parmi les plus américain des
martiniquais puisque vous partagez votre
temps entre fort-de-france et washington
bernard bûcher
on va rappeler que cette professeur de
médecine et de santé publique
internationale à l'université george
washington dans le district de columbia
bernard bûcher aujourd'hui les états
unienne vont élire leur 45e président
ont outre la démocrate hillary clinton
et le républicain donald trump en lice
également il faut quand même le rappeler
il y à gary johnson les libertariens
iliad gil stein c'est la candidate du
parti des verts et puis à ivan mac mini
nké candidat mormon entré tardivement
dans la course ne parle pas beaucoup de
ces trois dernières ces trois derniers
candidats mais jusqu'à hier soir bernard
bûcher
les deux principaux candidats livrer
bataille dans une campagne dominée
essentiellement par la forme beaucoup
d'agressivité d'agressivité beaucoup d'
attaque il ne faudra retenir pour cette
élection 2016 que cette forme dans ce
sens dans ce scrutin la non je ne pense
pas bon la forme traduit à mon avis
aussi le font parce que ce qui se passe
là c'est quand même un tournant il ya
deux conceptions de l'amérique qui
s'affrontent
comme beaucoup de pays les etats-unis
arrivent maintenant au xxème et xxième
siècle si on peut dire et à cause des
nouvelles donnes d'immigration les etats
unis sont obligés de savoir qui ils sont
vraiment et vous avez d'un côté par des
tensions et à la peur aux crispations je
vous rappelle que ce qui était
auparavant la majorité blanche
caucasienne devient maintenant la
première des minorités et face à ça il y
à l'émergence des minorités donc qu'un
composantes quelle diversité hockey
l'amérique c'est vraiment ça la question
je pense que c est la crise ils
devraient la question identitaire est
centrale je pense oui comme je pense
alors au fil des ans exactement parce
que c'est un phénomène mondial qui amène
les pays à se repositionner et là vous
avez deux visions de l'amérique
pourtant heures vous aimez dire que
devenir américaine aujourd'hui c'est
devenu un fait culturel avec l'avènement
de ces retraites barack obama c'est
exact jusque on peut dire à barack obama
c'était un fait politique
donc si vous reconnaissez la
constitution ce qui est ce que veut dire
la constitution de la vie de tous les
jours
alors vous pouviez être américain une
américains italiens américains
martiniquais je voulais on attendait ce
que maintenant être américain finalement
on est arrivé à la définition première
de la constitution et pluri blum à
partir de plusieurs nous formons un seul
ce qui veut dire que c'est une une
pluralité culturelle qui est qui est
désormais la culture américaine est la
vraie question aujourd'hui c'est où se
placent le curseur ou quelles sont les
valeurs que l'on retienne la nouvelle
immigration en apparence 2016 savoir
qu'ils avaient des latinos qui
franchissait le rio grande et sa part
n'a pas attendu 2016 pour savoir qu'il y
avait des boat people qui arrivait de
cuba et haïti on n'a pas oublié ses os
et afro américains exacte de la
communauté latino par exemple
aujourd'hui sa firme
elle s'affirme politiquement elle
s'affirme culturellement elle veut
prendre toute sa place il ya maintenant
des maires des sénateurs qui sont élus
comme c'est le cas également pour la
communauté haïtienne
donc tout ça doit trouver sa place est
d'ailleurs intéressant
on parle beaucoup du lary mais deux mots
sur bfm qui a été un des présidents les
plus intéressants des états unis des
plus fins analystes du pays qui donne un
discours récent disaient les états unis
vont évoluer
c'est une évidence mais la question
c'est en quels termes on dit souvent à
propos de ce scrutin de la nuit
prochaine que des états unis entre le
ont le choix entre la peste et le
choléra comme un aussi grand peuple
propulsé au devant de la scène mondiale
avec sa musique son cinéma ces sportifs
son industrie son armée comment ce
peuple là peut-il se contentent ils de
cette peste et de ce choléra pour
reprendre l'expression oui je pense qu'à
travers cette inspection les électeurs
d'en faire des citoyens américains
traduit quand même son désamour des
candidats qui sont qui sont présentés
des visions qui soit y en a trois autres
on ne parle jamais d'eux il aurait pu
représenter alors oui il va vous savez
que le système politique américain veut
que seuls des grands partis et pignans
sur wii
quand même beaucoup d'argent même
beaucoup d'argent pour mener une
campagne électorale à l'échelon d'un
pays qui quand même 22 froid la france
est en taille et donc le désamour c'est
que d'un côté
avait une espèce de mouvement du refuge
donc c'est donald rheault ce mouvement
là c'est un mouvement je dirais pour
traduire en termes français un peu
poujadiste à une crispation non à tout
et puis hillary clinton qui apparaît
malheureusement pouvait souvent comme le
candidat de l'establishment candidat de
washington
et c'est pas étonnant quand vous voyez
la répartition des intentions de vote
sur la carte des états unis que
l'intérieur des terres là où vous avez
l'amérique rurale se méfie beaucoup
d'elle et c'est quelqu'un qui n'est pas
forcément aimé qui respecte et qu'on sa
compétence mais pas forcément aimer et
c'est là la question c'est la question
de l'empathie
qu'est ce qu'un candidat doit ni aux
états unis un citoyen américain lorsque
lorsque comme donald 30 on arrive à un
tel niveau de succès personnel
quand même milliardaire comment peut-on
bénéficier de l'établissment de
fonctionner l'établissement ait pu
devenir aussi populiste
bon vous savez c'est quand même
quelqu'un de relativement opportuniste
c'est quelqu'un qui a commencé au parti
démocrate il ya une trentaine d'années
et puis la new york et puis qui m'ont
n'a pas pu être obtenu ce qu'ils
voulaient qui passer côté républicain
mais c'est quand même fondamentalement
une entrepreneure donc c'est quelqu'un
qui est dans le refus du système
totalement
c'est quelqu'un qui utilise le système
on l'a vu récemment avec avec ses
collègues il est rare et américaines
tout simplement
oui oui c'est une c'est une c'est une
partie c'est une vision il est américain
et la question c'est comment arrive-t-on
à réconcilier tout ça
une page est sûre ce soir une page sera
tournée puisque le premier président
noir élu sur demande à quittera la
maison blanche sur le bilan doit-on dire
un bilan mitigé
bernard bûcher oui on peut dire ça bon
barack obama de toute façon le fait de
son élection a changé la donne
il est clair que le rêve de martin
luther king devenu réalité la
possibilité pour quelqu'un d'être élu
sur son cv sur ses compétences et non
plus sous sa couleur de peau et ça ça
changera à jamais l'histoire des états
unis non par sa suite le président maman
a quand même n'a pas démérité ce qu'on
est arrivé au jeu rappelle un au milieu
de la crise des subprimes quelque chose
de terrible avec une inflation
épouvantable chômage terrible là
maintenant le chômage est à quatre et
demi pour cent il a sauvé les deux
scouts ont vu l'américaine donc il n'a
pas lieu de rougir le sont mais il a
échoué sur le plan de la santé sur le
plan de la santé
il a voulu mettre en avant
loi qu'on pourrait caractériser
d'européennes peut-être une loi qui ne
correspond pas vraiment à la philosophie
américaine qui peut-être le manque à
gagner c'est surtout ça il apparaissait
comme celui qui était le mieux placé
pour régler les questions de diversité
ça ne s'est pas refait on n'a jamais
attiré autant sur la communauté noire
lorsqu'on des policiers que pendant la
période obama oui je ne sais pas si
c'est exact il faudra regarder les
chiffres
mais disons la perception dans la lah en
termes de communication interne la même
saveur hauteur s'est passé hier pas
avant-hier pas de surmoi qui a beaucoup
de basques avant alex lowes se faisait
il n'y avait pas en communiqué pas à ce
sujet mais bon maintenant vous avez les
réseaux sociaux tout ça est
instantanément vous savez ce qui se
passe
donc il ya quand même ce manque à gagner
est peut-être finalement n'était-il pas
le mieux placé est prêtre qu'hillary
clinton si elle est élue si elle arrive
à mettre de l'ordre dans la maison sera
celle qui arrivera à gérer ça avec
peut-être des conseils précieux de bill
la question du racisme est très
importante aux états unis mais peut-être
pas forcément le racisme entre personnes
de couleur peut-être plus se mettre
l'accent sur le racisme économique
oui je pense que la partie émergée de
l'iceberg c'est quand même le racisme
peut effectivement de couleurs etc
mais derrière ce à travers les états
unis sont pays d'opportunités
donc la question est qui a le dollar qui
ne l'a pas et quand vous entendez qu'il
n'a pas c'est malheureusement souvent
les populations minoritaires notamment
la population noire
donc il ya une question d'accès aux
rêves d'accessibilité à l'entreprise
c'est là que ça se passe et c'est là que
vraiment si on veut avancer au 21e
siècle c'est là qu'il faut porter le fer
à travers notamment les questions
d'éducation
vous savez que le chômage américain est
un chômage non diplômés et la question
de l'accès à l'université de l'accès à
une profession de vie de tarifs des
universités effectivement c'est
prohibitif
il faut faire quelque chose à ce sujet
non c'est une connerie papa on peut
changer cette donne par exemple on peut
réduire le coût de la scolarité dans une
université aux états unis on peut
essayer
une des pistes au niveau des bourses de
choses comme ça mais puisqu'on parlait
concernant la loi sur la santé d'une
orientation européenne
parce que pour une fois peut-être
s'inspirer un peu de ce qu'on fait les
européens dans le domaine de la de
l'éducation vous savez les programmes
erasmus leonardo etc qui ont fondé le
socle d'une jeunesse européenne
finalement donc peut-être permettre aux
jeunes noirs de 2,6 ghz d'aller prendre
un coup on ne serait ce qu'un cours à
harvard de manière à ce qu'ils aient
accès aux gones d'université accès à
leurs réseaux
surtout parce que c'est ça c'est ça la
chanson là du tout pile à eau non pas
vraiment no et moi c'est quelque chose
qui est possible c'est une chose qui est
possible qu'il ne coûterait pas beaucoup
d'argent parce qu'il faut donner aux
générations futures la possibilité
d'être unis d'être divers et en même
temps unis je pensais en examen à
glissant que vous savez que la théorie
du du tout le monde a été a été vraiment
créé à new york par lui c'est pas pour
rien je pense qu'elle correspond au
21ème siècle
nous construisons un monde mais en même
temps c'est au monde construit de
petites pierres ces pierres sont en
résonance avec l'ensemble mais elles
peuvent garder leur identité elles
peuvent garder leur originalité c'est ça
à mon avis le challenge de la diversité
américaine janet mosaïque peut-être pas
métissé comme nous ont vraiment 10
secondes le premier le premier chantier
pour le futur président des américains
ce serait quoi mais dans l'immédiat je
pense que ce sera le management un peu
nettoyer les écuries d'augias
et puis gérer le système d'abord merci
d'avoir avec nous bernard du chan
appelle vous êtes professeur de médecine
et de santé publique internationale à
l'université george washington 10 mois
on méritait de colombiens